coach
[Laughter]
what's happened generational trauma I
swear
[Music]
we got a friend named Leslie in our um
in our JK IG DMS and she asked a really
great question which I thought you'd
have a lot of fun answering
what traits
of yours do you not want your kid to
inherit oh dude I can go on all too
[__] late dude so [__] Petty let's
start with you what oh yeah what is it
what do you
what are you [__] late that's too
late so like my a part of a trait of my
personality is I like to play [__] [__]
games [__] [__] game let's go so weird
uh can you define that yeah like I like
to play with fire a lot so if someone
tells me this is like out of bounds or
whatever I'm like [__] constantly
like you know like oh don't touch me I'm
not touching you I'm not like that kind
of [__] dumb [__]
this is part of my personality to be
like that yeah and taika has that like
[__] crazy and it's like built in
like you didn't teach him to do I didn't
teach him but don't you think that
because you understand that you can help
him through it better
uh but he never fixed it for himself
I think you're just impulsive
you know so it's hard to like help
someone who's impulsive fix things
because I like he'll just straight up go
out and do something like let's say I
see him like have like a rubber ball
just sees the TV right and I'm like I
know I know why you did that and I kind
of want to see what that would what
would happen too but I don't know how to
like really fix it it's just he just
does it and I I just won't kick his ass
the way my parents kick my ass yeah but
it's just I I sense the same kind of
like instinct you know and also to
answer Joe's question isn't Bart like
not a great teacher
he might be right there because didn't
he found a channel where I believe the
slogan if I'm not uh incorrect yeah is
teaching good things in a bad way in a
bad way yeah I don't think that's a very
good teacher if you turn around it says
just wait it out
but I think it's not literal bad I think
it's more like 90s cool bad nice like
how you look right now
Ferris Bueller baby
that could also be a Surf Ninjas Oh yeah
yeah so so right now we're teaching him
don't give me that yeah
he's like oh bro
so right now we're teaching him like
appropriate behavior like what you could
do at home what you could do at school
what are you doing public places and
stuff
and when he messes up he immediately has
to do like 10 or 20 squats or whatever
he knows when he messes up so like we'll
be at like let's say
um at a restaurant he just starts
socking me up you know he's being so
funny and I'm like hey don't hit me or
in public okay hold on we're just
playing you know but at home I don't hit
me on public that's not in a program I
want him to just like let's say we hang
out with you guys they just start
sucking you up because he just thinks oh
every adult I can just punch it's like
how's bull hit me though yeah yeah yeah
but I just want a video of it but don't
hit me and then he'll go like
I know
it's not 45 bucks hole Yeah so I
immediately I have to go I'm sorry
that's 10 squats and he was buying and
hit you I'm like what did I say about
playing with fire not even allowed to
put a fire so if even if it gets close I
want him to know like these are what the
hard boundaries are and you don't get to
even come close to the boundary you come
here he has to learn not to antagonize
people yeah so he didn't antagonize
anything it's smart that you're
associating Fitness with punishment too
that is a really good idea that is yeah
yeah because you'll be fat as [__] and
never want to do that yeah there's also
very military too it could be a TV
dinners guy yeah I am never getting fit
again yeah I mean but he's also like
a [__] head so like he's good at squats
now so he's literally going he's like
these aren't even that hard anymore Dad
no they're not that hard now he's like
yeah he could do a hundred house was
formed though it's actually pretty good
okay there you go I saw this clip uh
that popped up on my Instagram feed
about this guy talking about how there's
now research where children are born
with like 400 predisposed traits
of a collection of your genetics so all
of your shitty [__] behaviors from
your relatives
can be channeled through the child dude
my buddy has a daughter she's like nine
months old right and my buddy he always
it's weird he always puts his right leg
up wherever the [__] we are he always
puts his right leg up like on things and
I'm not even kidding he's like daughter
since she was like six months old she
just [__] does his thing it's the
weirdest thing same thing right like so
Jill sleeps like this for some reason
always on her right arm since taika was
a baby he always slept on his like right
arm real original so weird
yeah why these kids so bitey yeah like I
don't like that [__] biter ass b-o-g
what a poser if you just had to pick one
of your traits that you don't want your
kid to get which one is that which so
because I know you got so many but
what's the top one growing up my mom
would say I would do [__] like this like
that with Tycoon push you'd push the
limit [__] [__] games there's the limit
and I go okay I'm gonna get right I'm
not touching it you know like that type
of [__] oh just annoying like bratties
are great
Margaret used to do this thing where she
would count to like 10 or whatever right
just like all [__] yeah yeah and we
we had a pool in the backyard I couldn't
swim so I'd always like
step around it and be and I was supposed
to be around there right so I'd always
like put my foot over it and be like Mom
and I was like four or five years old
and then she'd count she'd be like all
right one yeah two and then I'm supposed
to be like running away from it and then
I'd count higher for her I'd be like
five six seven eight and then I I'd like
I'd jump around the pool yeah bro I
would just do [__] like that and then to
the point where I'd fall in the pool all
the time and I couldn't swim so my
scissors had to like save me a bunch
like this is just a common theme just
like little like we talked about I would
just put things in
um
electric sockets that's metal I always
wondered who did that I would do that
type of [__] you know I was like why did
I'm a kid why'd I get to put this
plastic [__] over this I just want to
plug in my radio yeah and because the
idiots like you put paper clips in there
oh I used to get Buckets stuck on my
head and like cry about it did you get
Lego stuck in your nose too no is it
because your ears were big no not even I
would I'd put a bucket on my head and I
thought it was funny and then it was
funny it is funny I'll get last right
and then I would put the handle under my
chin
and I'd start freaking the [__] out a
little Halloween bucket yeah yeah yeah
face on it I remember it was it was I
remember the bucket it was a blue bucket
that would use to shower with and it had
a yellow [__] uh handle and I got
stuck and I would freak the [__] out I'd
Panic so that's the trait you don't want
your kids that's one of the things
that's some funny boys and I was a
crybaby bro I was such a little cry baby
growing up I was a little softy because
I was raised by women dude it was like
three women yeah and my dad my dad used
to be like ah there's no hope for this
okay you know so I was like real soft
um when people would say things about me
start crying and [__] your dad recorded
on his boom he's like yeah it was good
ADR whatever the [__] turn
yeah he's like hey Nick can you like
scream in the hallway again but like in
the boom thank you so your main one is
is the trait of pushing the limit too
far I think so like amusements honestly
when I see taika I'm like damn bro
that's that's how I was when I was a kid
like I'm nowhere near that cool yeah I
wasn't that cool like I wasn't as funny
I definitely was a little but like I
would just do [__] and then I probably
wasn't as smart as taika either like I
was like yeah he's pretty smart yeah if
you like taika thinks I'm his age too
because he never tests me on [__] we
just get into trouble together
we're just playing and [__] is there
something about you you wouldn't want
your kid to have where do I [__]
start even like physical traits or like
anatomical ears dude Joe needs a
three-parter smaller ears
thank you
I have the patience not to [__] my kid
up because then I'm like more the older
I get it like and I see the kids and I'm
just like you know ah no wonder my
parents [__] me up like it's yeah
you're probably so stressed out and they
just don't listen and they test you and
[__] you think your kid's gonna be worse
than you were
with me and Hannah's genetics well it
could go so many different ways okay you
know because we have really chill guys
and but we also have some wild [__]
boys in the family well and she's hella
inbred right because she's she's super
inbred yeah yeah yeah but what about you
guys though yeah last two because I
typed a channeled a lot of traits for me
and and Geo yeah so like just from
YouTube because your kid's gonna pull
from you guys more than your family I
don't want them to have diabetes I don't
have diabetes but I'm predisposed to it
right yeah absolutely but
characteristics I would have to say
probably ADHD severe ADHD maybe yeah
um and then maybe uh yeah just letting I
mean just all boys just [__] don't
think you know they're impulsive and
wild I like that you're demonstrating
your severe ADHD right
because sometimes what is an
inconvenience and a crutch that's just
your perspective because you can't
navigate through it so I'm like how much
of that do I want to control that's what
I'm thinking because it might benefit
like they might be able to benefit that
trait in a way that I wasn't able to use
the right way it could be a phenomenal
thing yeah and a trait that's like when
you're five or six might not be good but
that same trade at like 25 might be
really good yeah yeah so I don't know
like I think I'm just thinking more
selfishly like I don't want them to be a
[__] annoying burden yeah and I hope
I have the patience to not knock them
out and like just be able to coexist
yeah me too
hit it with a stone cold stunner take
them out for Life they're gone they're
gone if they sell it though
one thing that typos Jiu Jitsu coach
told me that I was like almost about to
like just start falling immediately I
tell you guys about the time where like
tycho's learning this uh move called a
snapdown so you're pretty much grabbing
someone's head and you're snapping them
down and your partner is supposed to
like like brace and hit the map with
their forearms yeah so okay yeah yeah
yeah all right what's close
gotta go yeah and um so I think uh all
the kids were going full force and then
taika wasn't ready for it he's botching
it yeah like a bigger kid like smack him
and his face hits the map and he starts
crying immediately and when you're a kid
and you have something like crazy happen
you're like very shy now I don't want to
do it yeah no no he gets off the mat
he's want to do it or whatever and then
the the coach saw that he goes no no no
come on come on come on we get this is a
we can we can walk through he goes no I
don't want to do it he's like crying
because it just smacked his face it's
like like bruised and like bloody all
over his mouth he goes okay you do it to
me and so he let taika do it to him a
bunch of times and then he was doing as
he and then he he he switched it to him
and he does like the fake kind where
he's like but it's gentle and he kind of
built his confidence up cool and then he
was like okay now you can do it now to
get the other the original kid back yeah
and the title is able to complete it so
after class I was like hey coach DGL I
just want to like say like because he's
running a class you know and then I was
like um I just want to say I'm really
appreciative that you took the extra
time to spend on taika yeah
um and and it mattered a lot he goes
well like taika like those things are
breakthrough moments if you hit that
wall it either becomes it cripples them
for life or they become empowered yeah
it's make or break right there yeah oh
man thank you so much and I was like
that's so cool that you have the
patience and he goes because he goes no
one in this class enjoys Jiu Jitsu more
than taika oh because so because taika
is a [__] um
[__] sky
because of that he makes the class so
fun because the coach is like are you
grab him in like a chicken wing and then
everyone's okay cool everyone's like
this and tacos
like he's the only
oh like the boys fighting his own
genetics
he's like I just want to learn jiu jitsu
why am I doing
I hate that I do that genetically why my
father give me this [__]
coach
what's happening generational trauma I
swear
I'd say it was so cool for the coach to
be like like no one enjoys it more than
him that's great so if we can get him
through these tough times later on he's
gonna [__] love it he's like I've
seen it I've seen kids go from 5 to 18
and I've seen the journey just trust me
I'm like the sickest thing too is that
yeah how fake Jujitsu is she's about to
sell it
it's [__] that's so stupid
my thing is I'm so petty it's insane and
if and if anybody cites me I won't
forget it forever I won't I won't build
it I will build it into a mountain that
maybe doesn't even exist and I will
climb that mountain and I will Summit
that mountain I'll plant my flag on the
top of that mountain and then by the
time that I tell the person that I built
the mountain it's like wow I didn't know
that much like everybody who made fun of
you for crypto oh yeah yeah it's gonna
be a good in your face well my buddy
Sean he knows who he is
um when I was when I was getting into
crypto I remember getting into a couple
different projects and then yeah like um
you know we we did very very well right
and um we didn't really invest that much
and then we went down right and then he
was like if only we just held on to our
ethereum and I'm like well watch me
[__] I'm gonna do it again and
then
um the day and and I I I'm not kidding
I'm I'm weird every day I woke up and I
just like visualized telling this
[__]
that I did it again and uh and then it
happened and then I and then because
yeah because I'll never forget he told
our fancy Football chat he was like he
was like we could have been millionaires
if we just held on to our ethereum oh
[__] and then once I hit the million
again I was like hey dude
uh just so you know when you said if we
could have done it I did it again dude
off of nothing and then he was like oh
damn he's like
congrats first of all congrats and I was
like and that's not what I wanted
he was too good he didn't fight yeah and
it makes you feel bad because it's like
he was my enemy ah son of a yeah and I
actually really like this guy but it was
like that little that little slot that I
give him on my head where I'm like thank
you for the fuel this is gonna be great
and then the day that I did it I did it
live on crypto Corner because like the
day that you know when they hit like
[__] whatever it was like over a
hundred and I was like
[__]
right like I sent a little screenshot on
my portfolio which was ball of status
like off of a 28 000 investment and then
uh yeah he was just like congrats like
almost instantly he's just like congrats
that's awesome I'm really happy for you
and [__] and I was just like I need
something else to be mad about like I
don't have anything else and and I don't
you know maybe that is good for somebody
like having that fuel having those
little moments I don't necessarily know
where I would be if not for that because
I can cite many different little spurts
in my life of like upwards momentum
where I used something that someone
slided me with as like the fuel to get
me to the next step but I just hope that
they use it constructively like so far I
have so it's not like destructive and
yeah yeah like they end up slam dunking
on their friends so hard that it ruins
the Friendship I'm okay with slam
dunking on the friends so hard it ruins
the friendship
I just hope it doesn't ruin my kid like
that they needed that like it like eats
them up yeah yeah yeah like like it has
the best teacher dude it would be like
McFly when they call him yellowish
exactly like but enjoy the ride right
look there's nothing more fun than the
ride the ride is the most fun right like
like and and whether no matter what part
of the journey it is like it's the it's
the the way that like we talk about
YouTube in the early days when we were
grinding right when nobody knew who the
[__] we were that was the fun time it
was the fun times right we always talk
about that I mean granted we've had like
a Resurgence of the fun times I think
the fun times are here again yeah but it
really was like almost magical moments
of like we were nobody cared nobody knew
we walked around La and we told people
we did YouTube and they made fun of us
and agents made fun of us and Hollywood
directors and producers and everyone we
had the last laugh exactly now they're
all due ending videos so subscribe don't
forget to click the bell and I'm like I
can't believe that [__] we used to be so
embarrassed after say that [__] out loud
we were like shuddering to say that [__]
but but that's the magic is like that
perspective and I hope that my kid has
that kind of perspective about it like
knowing that you can use the field to
get the next step but then don't forget
like we don't step on people like I
don't want to step on people I really
don't that's not my jam I just want to
win and and I want to win because you
thought I would lose and I promise you
I'm gonna win because you thought I
would live sound like Jordan if I close
my eyes dude it's honestly I'm addicted
to it if I'm addicted to anything it's
that I can't do friendly competition
like I I get
you know that thing because I know like
David does a similar thing too but for
me as soon as it devours me when I
compete I want to destroy so it becomes
like
um I'm only motivated by enemies that I
want to absolutely Crush because it's
like the way you say Crush dude correct
you know why because to me it's like a
fair game
it's like fair game
it's like exactly it's like you
challenge me you slap me first so now
okay you mistaken kindness for weakness
let's go Cardinal holder I'm talking
about you I'm schooling you when it's
friends I genuinely want them to do so
well yeah me too if it even if it hurts
me so it's hard for me to be Petty
against friendship and it competition is
only okay if we agree to do it I don't
want the secret competition because yeah
that's weird
yeah even though I understand the way it
works I can't do it because then when I
get too much into it it turns into an
enemy thing in my head yeah like I don't
know how to go and like balance it to
where we can still be cool I'm like
really thinking about how I could not
only hurt you your family everything
yeah and it goes to it goes two oh I
don't go there yeah it goes way too dark
that's wild so it's like
any uh physical traits that you'd want
your son to inherit from you besides
height all right from a physical point
of view I I
I'm too hairy in certain places that I
don't want to be like where your [__]
my [__] I got my 45 bucks hole but I
do wish I had the hair that could
connect my facial hair and make it full
so you know does does Nina have it on
her side like right here not Nina but I
heard the dudes in her family then they
got like her dad and her uncle I don't
see it on her dad or I see the mustache
yeah oh yeah but not like a full
connected like the ability to like shape
like I covered Ryan's facial hair you
could have it bro would you feel like
shortchanged if your kid wasn't as tall
as you no because need a shorter so I
expect it I'm surprised I grew taller
than my parents uh but most people grow
taller than their parents right well in
my experience
my parents told me when I was growing up
that my younger brother Nate he weighed
more than me at Birth so he was always
going to be taller than me and I swear I
willed
I am tallest person in my entire [__]
family and they told me the entire time
I was growing up that I wouldn't be they
told me the entire time I was growing up
that my younger brother and I swear to
God on my life I willed it into it and
then the day you got brother taller than
your brother you looked at him you're
like I'm [__] talking and he was like
congrats no no how about this they're
young like I said younger brothers they
never got taller than me but I kept on
[__] growing because I knew I knew to
win I knew to keep that [__] Basic
Instinct and probably just laying on
your bed going yeah length hitting my
[__] spine and [__] dude hanging
upside down
[Laughter]
what physical trait out of your whole
like self would you you wouldn't mind
seeing your kid look like that I
wouldn't mind yeah you'd like it what do
you like in terms of like uh something
you could pass down the hair hair
you got nice hair your wrist you want to
press down your wrist yeah yeah the sex
havary except if it's a girl oh yeah
actually personality trait wise that's a
dope thing for your kid to have like
we'll talk about tomorrow the smoothness
the kindness the Anthony Lee Kessler the
Anthony empathy always second place
empathy Lee empathy Lee
that's a good name for your kid empathy
Lee he's gonna get punked that's gonna
be a stripper that's a stripper's name
Here Comes empathy and it was like yeah
get the dollar bills out get the singles
out put the fives away put the fives
away this is the trash break the fives
shoot the quarters I get the nickels
I think this is a boring answer but I
think the disease is probably the number
one thing that's very important to me
and I would feel horrible yeah like I
don't want to pass down eczema rare
diseases anything like that Crohn's
disease me too too true
thank you